I'm very pleased interest to you Brian
crew damn Brian thank you for the
introduction president Cohen good
morning fellow graduates friends faculty
honored guests family hi mom oh I love
these robes in my head I'm a young
wizard graduating from Hogwarts that's
all I ever wanted ok I want to start off
by saying I am NOT cool and i would
venture to say that for many of us
gathered here today the statement holds
some truth we were never considered one
of the cool kids there's just something
different about us I see some nods in
agreement and I also see some confused
looks that's okay before you get
offended allow me to explain why this
matters I want you to think back to an
earlier time try to recall what it felt
like at that very early stage of your
existence though may feel like light
years away from where we are today
remember those lazy afternoons holed up
in your room reading calvin and hobbes
it was a time when if someone asks you
what do you want to be when you grow up
you could probably answer with just
about anything astronaut firefighter
president of the united states harry
potter it was a time when who and how we
would be in this world was not yet
urgent not yet fraught with obstacles
expectations or self doubt it was a time
when we could just be and that was
enough there's that one calvin and
hobbes comic strip where calvin is
leaning against a tree with his arms
crossed looking disaffected Hobbs goes
up to Calvin and
asks what are you doing to which Calvin
replies being cool Hobbes remarks you
look more like you're being bored and
Calvin just shrugs and responds the
world bores you when you're cool here's
what I know now that I didn't know back
then the world shouldn't bore you and if
that's what it takes to be cool then I
don't want to be cool here at CMU we
aren't bored and we don't care about
being cool that's what I love about us
we've all grown up and as we've grown up
we were taught to police ourselves in
accordance to cool it's not cool to show
too much motion it's not cool to be
vulnerable it's not cool to pour your
heart into your work not here not at CMU
and we learned that the day we moved in
I'm sure you remember that giant flock
of students who rushed toward us like a
giant tidal wave it was terrifying names
are exchanged hugs were given and
received and then suddenly our bags were
coaxed from our weary hands by our
endlessly enthused orientation
counselors as they led us to our new
homes or if you lived in mudge house to
new mansion
there was not a shred of self conscious
posing from our fellow Oh Sees that
night I remember milling around Mudge
courtyard stuffing my face with nachos
and cheese while introducing myself to
you guys I wanted to meet as many people
as possible because my high school years
had instilled this cautious instinct
within me to think that if I didn't make
a good impression right away it'd be too
late but as the night wore on I quickly
realized that none of that stuff
mattered anymore what mattered was the
crackling energy in the August air that
made us feel like we could stay away all
night making those first tentative steps
towards friendships that would last us
to the end of our days whether you're an
undergraduate student or a graduate
student I'm sure you realized that it
was pretty clear cool wasn't even on the
table there was too much experience too
much to explore here to waste time
worrying about being cool when someone
says that's cool on this campus let me
give you some examples of what that
means cool here is when Christian races
over to the UC black chairs in between
his classes he can't wait to show
everyone the snake game he's built over
the weekend using just a wiimote and
some LEDs cool here is when pooja spends
all day selling krispy kremes on behalf
of her dance team tunne so they can
raise enough money for competition and
then she stays up all night practicing
her choreography over and over again
even though she hasn't examd the next
morning cool here is when Andrew camps
out at the fence in the middle of the
winter just to paint three Greek letters
alpha kappa sigh because he's brimming
with pride and accomplishment and having
just joined a fraternity cool here is
realizing that this school and all the
opportunities that has given us is worth
our time our enthusiasm our hard work
and sometimes our lack of sleep leaning
against a tree to avoid awkwardness
masking how you really feel by looking
disengaged and doing nothing is the
farthest thing from cool here my time at
CMU ended a semester early last December
I have the opportunity to move out to
the bay area and start a company with
three friends from freshman year we had
this idea what if you could link the
cards in your wallet to your
fingerprints to pay for things you never
need around you to carry around plastic
cards again we knew our idea would meet
a lot of skepticism fear and in some
cases outright rejection but we just
kept going and going and we built our
product pay tango here at CMU and no one
stopped us I really should give a
special thank you to president Cohen for
making it part of his mission to build a
community where learning meets
entrepreneurship CMU took a chance on my
team seeing you agree to pilot our
technology in its dining halls when
everyone else said it was too risky or
simply too early our first users were
you guys CMU students who kept using the
product and giving us valuable feedback
even when it was slow and sometimes
broken CMU faculty and alumni were the
first people we turn to for advice
although i was living across the country
in san francisco during my last semester
it felt like I never left Pittsburgh I'm
so grateful to each and every one of you
who have helped us along the way CMU
took a chance on all of us that day we
got our fat letter in the mail so let's
not forget to continue to pay it forward
and take chances on ideas and people
even if it makes you the most uncool
person in the room we must listen before
we judge those ideas that seem out there
and be patient with those people whose
opinions are so different that it might
seem scary at first class of 2013 we
graduate today older wiser but not
cooler at least by the standard
definition I would invite you to join me
and reject
this rigid code of cool but you know
what I don't need to because in the span
of these four years you already have we
have already chosen to be among the
explorers and inventors the creators and
leaders the perpetually enchanted the
ones who will never cease to be amazed
by the wonders of our world and I have
no doubt my fellow graduates that when I
bump into you whether it's a year from
now or 20 years from now I will find you
among those who are too busy living too
busy caring and too busy carrying on
that tart and spirit to be cool
congratulations
you